Good evening.
I trust you had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, but I hope it has been happy.
Namo dasa bhagavato arahato sama sambodasa.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed Noble and fully self-awakened one.
So this is the 65th YouTube broadcast.
So I think we're slowly coming to an end.
Mind you, there's lots of scriptures.
Anyway, we'll carry on with this number 77, the Sakkuludai Sutta.
So it's a wonderer called Sakkuludai.
And we switched really to the teaching of the Buddha himself, which were the 37 facts of enlightenment.
But the opening of it is an interesting conversation.
And so we'll have a look at that.
So as usual, the Blessed One was going out for alms, but he was a bit early, so he went to the shrine at Rajagaha, that's Rajgir, where King Bimbisara lived, just north, well, along the Ganges.
It's called the Peacock's Sanctuary.
And there was a loud, loud
there were a large assembly of wanderers who were making an uproar loudly and noisily talking about many kinds of pointless things.
Now, what would be these pointless things?
Well, such talk of kings, robbers, ministers, armies, dangers, battles, food, drink, clothing, beds, garlands, perfumes, relatives,
vehicles, villages, towns, cities, countries, women, heroes, streets, wells, the dead, trifles, the origin of the world, the origin of the sea, whether things are so or are not so.
So those are the sorts of conversations that I think we all have at one point or another, but not particularly aiming at liberation.
And so just, you know, just ordinary prattle of ordinary daily life.
So anyway, when Sakuladayin sees the Buddha coming, he says, Oh, quiet, sirs, make no noise.
Here comes the recluse Gautama.
This venerable one likes quiet and commands quiet.
Perhaps if he finds our assembly a quiet one, he will join us.
So you get the feeling that, you know, there were a group of wanderers
probably, you know, somewhere around the Buddha's age, whom he knew well, and they knew him.
And that's why on the way to arms, the Buddha thinks to himself, I shall go to the sanctuary to have a chat with Sakuladayin.
Anyway, when he arrives, they all sit there, you see, and
the buddha wants to know what they were talking about and sacrifice says i forget that you know let's uh i want to talk about something a bit more uh to the point and he says this so he's now comparing uh the other major teachers of the time about five or six of them uh with the buddha and how the disciples treat them so this purana kasapa is the head of an order regarded by many as a saint yet
He is not honoured, respected, revered and venerated by his own disciples, nor do his disciples live in dependence on him, honouring and respecting him.
Once Purana Kasapa was teaching his Dharma to an assembly of several hundred followers.
Then a certain disciple of his made a noise.
Sirs, do not ask Purana Kasapa this question.
He does not know that.
We know that.
Ask us that question and we will answer it for you, sirs.
It happened that Purana Kasapa did not get his way, though he waved his arms and wailed.
Be quiet, sirs.
Make no noise, sirs.
They are not asking you, sirs.
They are asking us.
We will answer them.
Indeed, many of his disciples left him after refuting his doctrine thus.
You do not understand this Dharma and discipline.
I understand this Dharma and discipline.
How could you understand this dharma and discipline?
Your way is wrong.
My way is right.
I am consistent.
You are inconsistent.
What you should have said first, you said last.
What you should have said last, you said first.
What you had so carefully thought up has been turned inside out.
Your doctrine is refuted.
You are proved wrong.
Go and learn better or disentangle yourself if you can.
This is Purana's
earlier disciples who become disenchanted with him.
Now, although they say that about these different teachers, obviously a bit of an exaggeration, no doubt, do remember that towards the latter part of the Buddha's life, his own cousin Devadatta rebelled against him, tried to kill him, it would seem, and started his own order elsewhere.
So it wasn't just these people.
However, at this present time, the Buddha has this great reputation.
So now, once now compared to that, he says, once the recluse Gautama was teaching his Dharma to an assembly of several hundred followers.
And there a certain disciple of his cleared his throat.
Thereupon, one of his companions in the holy life nudged him with his knee.
quiet, venerable Serbian, make no noise.
The blessed one, the teacher, is teaching us the Dharma.
When the recluse Gautama is teaching the Dharma to an assembly of several hundred followers, on that occasion, there is no sound of his disciples coughing or clearing their throats.
See, so there's this great respect.
So now, so the...
Udayin, how many qualities do you see in me because of which my disciples honour, respect, revere and venerate me, live in dependence on me, honouring and respecting me?
Okay, so Saludayin replies, Venerable Sir, I see five qualities.
The blessed one eats little and commends eating little.
The second one is that he is content with any robe and commends contentment with any robe.
that he is content with any kind of alms food and commands contentment with any kind of alms food.
That one is content with any resting place and commands contentment with any resting place.
And that the venerable one is secluded and commands seclusion.
So the first four are what we call the four requisites.
So it's food, clothing,
arms food and resting place.
Oh, I've just realized he hasn't got medicine, just arms food, really.
So it's commends not eating so much and to be happy with arms food.
So that's really just one requisite.
Then there's the robes, the clothing, and then there's the resting place.
And finally, secluded and commends seclusion.
So he's left out medicine there, I don't quite know why.
So now the Buddha asks him...
So the Buddha says, okay, yeah, that's true, but there are disciples of mine who live on a cupful or half a cupful of food, a bilver's fruit and half a bilver's fruit quantity of food, while I sometimes eat the full contents of my arm's bowl and even more.
So what he's saying is, yeah, fine, he does this, but he himself might not be the best exemplar, right?
There are disciples of his who really do eat little, but what he's saying is I eat the contents of my bowl, et cetera.
There are disciples of mine who are refuse rag wearers, wearers of coarse robes,
They collect rags from the charnel ground, rubbish heaps or shops, make them into patched robes and wear them.
But I sometimes wear robes given by householders, robes so fine that pumpkin hair is coarse by comparison.
Okay?
So what he's saying is that he's not the exact exemplar of all these commendations.
Now there are disciples of mine who are armed food takers,
go on unbroken arms round from house to house who delight in gathering their food when they've entered among the houses they do not consent even when invited to sit down but i sometimes eat on invitation meals of choice rice and many sauces and curries
And the final, and then there are disciples of mine who are tree root dwellers and open air dwellers, who do not use a roof for eight months of the year.
In the rainy season, you need a roof, of course.
While I sometimes live in gabled mansions, plastered within and without, protected against the wind, secured by door bolts with shuttered windows.
Okay.
And then there are disciples of mine who are forest dwellers, dwellers in remote resting places, who live withdrawn in remote jungle thicket resting places and return to the midst of the Sangha once every half month for the recitation of the Patimokkha.
That's the rules.
But I sometimes live surrounded by bhikkhus and bhikkhunis, by men and women lay followers, by kings and kings' ministers, by other sectarians,
and their disciples okay so in other words although he has commended these things he himself is not a particularly good exemplar of it right so why is it then that uh the disciples do honor and esteem okay so the first one so then he says to udayin my disciples esteem me for the higher virtue
The recluse Gautama is virtuous.
He possesses supreme aggregates of virtue.
This is the first quality because of which my disciples honor, respect, revere and venerate me and live in dependence on me, honoring and respecting me.
So it's because people recognize his virtue that they honor him.
And then they esteem me for my excellent knowledge and vision.
When the recluse Gautama says, I know, he truly knows.
And when he says, I see, he truly sees.
The recluse Gautama teaches the Dharma through direct knowledge, not without direct knowledge.
He teaches the Dharma with a sound basis, not without a sound basis.
He teaches the Dharma in a convincing manner, not in an unconvincing manner.
So that's to do with his teaching ability.
It comes from his own personal experience and therefore has that ring of truth about it.
They esteem for higher wisdom the recluse Gautama is wise.
possesses the supreme aggregate of wisdom it is impossible that he should not foresee the future courses of doctrines in other words how his what the implications will be of his teachings and that he should not be able to confute with reason the current doctrines of others right so in other words he's uh his wisdom is based on on uh
His wisdom is based on direct experience.
And therefore, when he actually explains it, it comes out as logical, straightforward and truthful.
When my disciples have met with suffering and become victims of suffering, pray to suffering, they come to me and ask me about the noble truth of suffering.
Being asked, I explain to them the noble truth of suffering and I satisfy their minds with my explanation.
They ask me about the noble truth of the origin of suffering, the noble truth of the cessation of suffering and the noble truth of the way leading to the cessation of suffering.
Being asked, I explain to them the noble truth of the way leading to the cessation of suffering and I satisfy their minds with my explanation.
This is the fourth quality
whereby people, whereby my disciples honour me.
So he's pointing out there are four things that bring about a great respect for him.
The first one is his virtue, his goodness, his goodness power, punya.
The second one is that he really comes from direct knowledge, personal direct knowledge.
The third one is that he
That when he teaches, it's obviously an expression of deep wisdom.
And the fourth one is that he actually shows them the path, the practical way of becoming liberated from suffering.
So that's the conversation that he has with Sakuludai in the peacocks.
What is it?
In the peacocks.
Where are we?
In the peacock sanctuary.
So I hope that's been of, I don't know, some form of enlightenment.
The way the Buddha talks, the way the Buddha sees himself is portrayed here.
I can only hope that this little reading has been of some assistance and that you will, by your practice, liberate yourselves from all suffering sooner rather than later.
So we can do a little practice.